coming up on today's show we have
in studio with us actor sean patrick
flannery
he's going to give us his thoughts on
fame the difference between working on a
television set and a film set
and how he prepared for the role of
conor mcmanus in his latest movie
the boondock saints 2 all saints day to
see more on sean you can visit
sean flannery and that's flannery with
1n.com
today's show is sponsored by wendy
shepard of studio matrix
do you need to know the steps involved
in getting a website up
or need the help of website design do
you have questions with about an
existing website or how to get traffic
to it studio matrix can answer these
questions and more
save time and money gain ideas and
advice from people with
experience to see what wendy can do for
you please visit studiomatrix.com
we are thrilled to have with us today
actor sean patrick flannery
his credits include the adventures of
young indiana jones
powder the boondock saints and the
boondock saints 2
all saints day all right welcome to the
studio show shaun thanks very much good
to be here absolutely good to have you
if you would like to participate in
today's show or future shows you can
reach us through twitter.com
film courage or through email
filmcourage gmail.com
i would like to participate where you're
not talking to me no that's all right
okay we're ready to participate with you
right here we go
all right all right so john let's let's
start out at the very beginning take us
back so
where did you grow up and uh how did you
become interested in acting
uh i was born in lake charles louisiana
you know a tiny little town in louisiana
um then my folks moved uh
with me of course they didn't leave me
four years old
we went to a little town outside of
houston in texas
and i grew up there you know pretty
normal upbringing have wonderful parents
uh there's no none of this artist like
who i i
owe my craft for the turmoil that was my
youth nope no crap like that you know
my wonderful parents had a wonderful
childhood both my parents went to
every sporting event i ever competed in
what kind of sports uh every everything
except obviously it's texas i know ice
hockey you know okay
uh no basketball ice hockey actually
or baseball yeah big big big bit of
controversy here but anything that you
can play an entire game
uh during chew tobacco and not break a
sweat to me is not really a sport
i'm gonna offend so many people by
talking about baseball like that but
if you can be fat and not break a sweat
and play an entire game in it
doesn't really interest me too much but
uh you know so everything everything
other than that other than that yeah
and then how do how do you become
interested in acting where does how does
that begin
you know i was going to university of st
thomas and uh
i saw a girl leaving a building on a
monday
and i wanted to know what the hell was
going on in that building
that interested her and that's true
story actually i know it sounds absurd
and ridiculous but uh
so i dropped an english class i signed
up for uh it happened to be acting
and i fell in love with acting uh my my
uh
uh the drama teacher was sam havens a
wonderful
uh theater director producer et cetera
and uh i started doing plays you know
you know all around houston and whatnot
and
and at the end i decided i was gonna
when i graduated i was gonna
pack up my car and move out and uh you
know do
do some uh theater out in l.a so is it
is it fade is it destiny i mean
that's that's pretty wild you know and
then did you get a chance to actually
speak to that girl yeah did anything
happen with you yeah yeah yeah she ended
up being a fruitcake but uh
i i i i dug uh acting guys like that
yeah yeah not this level of fruitcake
this is a different level altogether
this is this turbocharged fruitcake
uh no but but uh you know uh for
whatever reason it kind of
brought me into that building fell in
love with it and uh i i decided i wanted
to
you know do something with it i had a
ball doing it and i thought man if you
know
it was never my wildest dreams to become
a working
actor per se because that seemed more
like a lottery win
but i knew that i could make money in
the industry whether it was uh
saving up my money producing my own play
renting out my own playhouse and
writing my own piece and doing it doing
it that way i i would have been content
with that but
i got an agent and she was like you know
let me submit you for some commercials i
said
what the hell you know let's check it
out and i got a couple commercials you
know which was
a little mini lottery win for me really
and then she said you know why don't we
see if we can submit you on some
theatrical stuff i was like yeah okay
sure
meanwhile i'm still you know writing and
working towards uh
theater production and then i got some
acting roles you know outside of
commercial some real ones and then the
next thing you know i was
auditioning for young indiana jones so
it was it just kind of happened you know
it's uh you know and i thought it was
wonderful it was great
kind of right away i mean did you go
through the typical you know couch
surfing eating ramen noodles
all that or did you just things just
kind of just fell into place yeah no you
know i i never really understood the
couchsurfing ramen noodle thing i mean i
mean whether i'm an actor or not i mean
i was waiting tables and i was waiting
making good money i mean for a single
dude i made
when i left houston i came out here and
waited tables and i realized man
i could like raise a family on this kind
of money i mean you know you're talking
about
you know 300 bucks a night cash uh you
know i was making
you know six seven thousand bucks a
month with not no bills
you know so so really i mean i was
working a lot of hours but
i was never the kind of guy that's like
i'm not gonna work i'm i'm gonna wait to
make it in
in my craft i'm i was going to take care
of myself regardless so
you know i i i i definitely wasn't
you know struggling too much financially
because just waiting tables hard work
right yeah so you know so you move from
from from the texas to los angeles
you know and you're going to take your
shot at acting can you go into a little
bit more detail about these early days
in terms of your mindset in los angeles
yeah i mean l.a was la was a you know
it's a brand new
frontier for me you know i mean you hear
all the stories but uh
it's it's exactly what people said you
know when uh uh right right now you know
occasionally you know uh somebody
younger will say you know what's the
best advice you can give and i say well
you know don't forget where you came
from don't forget that your first job
you would have paid to do for example if
scorsese came and said you know i'm
gonna put you in this movie but you
gotta pay me five grand
you would find five grand you would call
everybody you know and you would get
sponsors
you'd come up with five g's it's the
only job i know that's like that
i mean you find me a ditch digger and
ask him you know what your first ditch
you dug would you pay it to do it they
they'd laugh at you you're like no
i wouldn't pay to do this you're gonna
pay me for the first one
you gotta pay me for the first shovel
that hits the dirt for me to dig a ditch
or any other occupation for that matter
this is the only job where
you'd pay the first year to do it right
and uh people forget that you know cut
two six years later they're on a show
they're not coming out of their trailer
they're angry they're bitter they're
resentful for whatever reason and i just
tell them to not don't forget that you
know because it's uh
i mean we're lucky to truly be doing
something it it's
you know like your dad always said you
know do something you love and you'll
never have to work a day in your life
you know probably 0.01 percent of the
people actually find something like that
so you know we're really lucky to be
doing you know people pay us to do this
and it's really just kind of
we're faking it you know so you know
it's just that
that's the best advice i can get and
you've had to deal with various levels
of fame
is being famous something that you've
craved i mean
did it have anything to do with you
pursuing acting what are your thoughts
on fame
um you know i really can't answer that
with any degree of knowledge because
i've never really experienced it
i mean people i did young indiana jones
chronicles but
maybe you and three other people saw it
so so i mean it's something i'm
incredibly proud of but
it's not anything that i'd walk down the
street and people go oh my god you're a
young indie
um powder nobody nobody really knows
that i did that until you know
six months after i've met him and then
somebody says ah did you ever see that
movie he did and they're like what what
are you talking about you know so it's
not like
i get recognized it's occasionally
somebody will be like wow you look
like the guy that did such and such did
you get that a lot and i'll be like yeah
i i do get that
ah yeah yeah cool all right take care
you know they they
they never asked it was really mean so i
i have no idea
um i haven't said that i wouldn't trade
my anonymity for anything
okay i think anonymity allows you to be
a real human being
you know if i go into a restaurant and
somebody gives me crap service i can go
excuse me
i asked you five times you know and i
was a waiter and i was very good at it
so it's the fifth time i've asked you if
i could just have water
just some water right you know i can do
that without being
that actor that like came in and
complained you know if tom cruise does
somebody go oh tom cruise on table five
was like
yelling at people because he didn't have
some water
actually there's a website i think that
like outs people
like that are in restaurants yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think it allows you to just
be
a normal person you know and and how how
long was before you got you got your big
break before before
you know things started where you could
just lean on acting where you could get
out of the
out of waiting tables and just kind of
only do acting
you know pretty much every everything i
mean if you're just speaking financially
where
you don't have to do anything to
subsidize it it would be
it it's it's very subjective because for
me everyone was a big break
i mean could i have lived the year off
the first commercial i did
yeah i could but i'm not one of those
guys that quit waiting tables until i
had something that occupied so much time
i couldn't wait tables
whereas i had friends that were waiting
tables that they'd get one episode of
something they'd quit
and then six months later they came back
to wait and dip i never wanted to be
that guy that
came back to the restaurant you know so
uh i mean when i left to go do young
idiot i had three national commercials
running i did two little things for walt
disney
channel um i i certainly could have
lived for a couple of years on that
alone but i was never gonna be that dude
that like
cashed out too early and thought he had
made it you know so i i quit i think
four days before i got on a plane to go
to
london to start doing young indy you've
done countless interviews
in your career does it get tiring um it
gets tiring when people ask the same
question over and over again but you
know i mean this is pretty organic so
we're just chatting so
i i dig this you know i mean you know
the the the typical question over and
over again
you try to make it sound like it's the
first time you've answered it but
sometimes it comes off like
wow this guy said this 96 times you know
right
and why why are you doing interviews
such as you know or why are doing
interviews such as this one important
what are the benefits to you what do you
get out of these uh well
i mean you know i have a movie coming
out right now uh
certainly uh myself and everybody in
production involved would like people to
go and see the film
um it's an independent film so it's not
gonna get as much advertising coverage
it's not gonna be on
you know every commercial break it's not
gonna be on every billboard so
you know the requirement for the actors
is much higher than you know bigger film
we have to go out there and
do interviews and let people know that
it's coming out because there's a lot of
fans that
are still asking me for example like ah
when are you guys gonna make boondock
too
and and i'm like well it we actually did
and it's coming out
in three weeks you know so you've had
people even up even
the other day or just recently that are
that are asking you about yeah of course
you know people people still
uh on the interwebs they'll ask a
question exactly like that
you know i heard that y'all are going to
make all say today when's that is that
going to reach fruition uh actually it
did
and we've already completed locked
picture and sound and
it's going to be coming to theaters in
three weeks so let's go back to the
actor thing
you know thousands of people come here
every day and
with the dream of you know breaking into
tv film whatever
what do you think has enabled you to
succeed i mean what separates you from
those that haven't made it
i think realistically it's like anything
in life i think you have to properly
assess your ability
i think people that miscalculate and mis
misinterpret what they have in any
certain field
there's a big difference between wanting
to do something and being able to do
something
and you really have to check your ego at
the door to say
am i going to be competitive with this
cross-section of talent
and you know a lot of times you watch
some of the reality shows today and it's
just
ever present you know you watch american
idol and some of these people truly
believe that they can sing i mean you
can look in their eyes and they truly
believe
they're dumbfounded why they didn't make
it past the first round
and the whole audience is like oh my god
you can't carry a tune
not one tune i think you have to
properly assess you have to be honest
with yourself and say
i can be competitive with this
cross-section and if you're fairly
accurate to that mark
i think you have a good shot you know
and that goes with any field you know
certainly you're not there's not a lot
of people that want to be
uh you know fluid dynamics uh engineers
that can't uh you know do do mathematics
you know they can't write an algorithm
certainly that's a prerequisite you have
to be honest with yourself and your
professor's going to tell you you know
you don't need to know string theory but
you need to know fundamentals of the
math
right you know so maybe simon cowell
isn't as bad as
he's saving people time you know what i
mean it really is in this industry it's
a harsh
reality you know you need to let
somebody know and and it may
be unfortunate but realistically what
would you rather would you rather
somebody go oh you know keep at it keep
trying somebody that's like sounds like
a dog dying
really or do you want somebody that may
may hurt their feelings for a day
but at least they're going to pursue
something that they can actually achieve
something in
cut their losses yeah exactly simon
cowell i mean he cuts to the point but
i'd rather somebody say that
i mean if i sucked ass at something i
don't want somebody to say you know what
realistically
it's not going to happen for you in this
field save me time and let me pursue
something else so did you have those
people early on for you that
that helped you kind of assess yourself
and evaluate yourself
um you know like what was it about you
that city that that you where you had
that belief where
i can do this you know having said
exactly what i just now
said i fall into that category where i
just think i had a more accurate beat on
it because i certainly did think
i could do this you know you never know
to what level but when i see people
on the screen i'm like i can do it at
this level maybe it's not
the premiere level but it's something
that gets aired
you know having said that it's uh you
know somebody could have looked at me
and said wow that kid's delusional
you know but uh i
i put myself in a peer group and that
peer group you know
we're making commercials a peer group
was was being employed in
you know basic level television stuff
and i thought you know
if somebody if an agent a reputable
agent pursues me
and said we want to submit you on these
things i thought wow well this reputable
agent has a number of clients
that are working and they think i should
well that's the first
little you know thing to check off on
your list it's not me thinking i can do
it it's somebody that pursued me
because you know i came out to produce
plays so when i said that i thought that
i'll give it a shot
how do you go about building your fan
base i mean is this something that you
consciously do
uh how do you build your network you
call wendy shepard
at studiomatrix or officiallyblog.com
yeah that's exactly what you do
i have no clue um you know when when i
first stepped up with wendy
uh you know i mean she would say things
like well you know you have to do this
on facebook you have to do this on
myspace and then you should really tweet
her about this and that
and on your website you should have like
well why but i i i have none of those
none of the above
you know she was kind of dumbfounded and
uh you know she said well how do you
interact with fans or i said i
you know smoke signals i don't know i
give up uh you tell me
and you know she put together my website
for me she put together the myspace page
and the facebook and
as nonsensical as a lot of it sounds
it's imperative
if you want to be communicative with
your fan base you really you really have
to have these things
um and lo and behold i have
a huge number of fans that want to
communicate and there's pertinent
information things that helped me out in
my career thing
likes dislikes um it's it's
it's a crucial tool in today's market um
but before i met her
i just kind of went from acting jobs
acting job and
i had a ball doing it but i had no idea
the likes dislikes and
the fans really love that interaction
they really do
i mean it's monumental to them you know
and
quite honestly i enjoy it as well you
know but it's all wendy shepard she put
it all together i mean she's
a specialist and you know driving
traffic to the website and how to
promote this and uh so
you know if anybody has any questions
wendy shepard at officiallypluggedin.com
uh or studio matrix you know though
that's i i can't recommend
anybody more highly that's awesome now
in terms of the young actor listening
right now
um you know how imperative do you think
it is for them in terms of
what should they be focused on should
they be focused on on on the craft of
acting the train you know or
do you think they should begin to
incorporate you know building a little
bit of a fan base at the same time
you know has the game changed uh you
know it depends on what you want to do
you know if you want to be a serious
actor
uh i i may be the wrong guy to start
talking about craft too
because uh uh i'm not a big
uh well i'm not a big acting class kind
of guy
um all of my research oddly enough you
know so many people say to me you know
like wow what was your
what was your uh what did you go through
you know researching your role for
powder what was your process
internal and external i'm like brother
my process started on page one and ended
it fade out
every bit of information that i need to
do a movie
is in script you know i don't need to
live on the street for
six weeks and peek in my own clothes to
know what it's like to be homeless i can
kind of imagine what it'd be like
so i may be the wrong guy to ask it's a
it's a simple job
not a lot of people can do it well but
having said that
you're never going to find somebody that
cannot act at all
and they go to school for two years and
then suddenly they can you're never
gonna find that person there's a reason
that all good acting schools
auditioned to get in they auditioned to
get in
you know the actors studio they they
they had paul newman well paul
newman was paul newman the first day he
showed up there was paul
newman
you know what i mean absolutely you saw
me you show me some you know
inept chachi that ends up being paul
newman and i'll shut up
you know but all these guys were were
working actors the day they
walked in to the active studio or
whatever or whoever
howard fine or chachi sinclair whoever
that's that's in la you know charging
people a grand a month to learn how to
act i've never once in my life
and i've been doing this 20 years found
somebody that couldn't act but then went
to school and came out
being a great actor never never there's
tricks that you can learn
with the camera um but but those are
technical
it's all technical you can either
deliver a realistic line reading or you
can't period
so you need almost a level of intuition
yeah yeah it's innate it's something
you're born with and i'm not saying i'm
great at it but uh
but there are people at very different
levels but some people
i don't care what you do they just they
they cannot some people aren't even
believable as themselves
i mean some people like when you're
talking like wow if we were filming this
you'd come off as a bad actor you know
what i mean some people are like that
and no offense they're they're probably
great at a number of things that i suck
at
um or other people may be great at or
suck at some things but
it's just not something that you can
teach somebody to be relaxed and it you
can't teach somebody
to get over stage fright you can teach
someone to
compartmentalize and to minimize you
know just things that you either have
you don't have
and no no no you know inward reflection
is going to go around that
so you know in your daily life are you
are you always acting
you know are you seeing someone do
something funny and copying that or you
know
do you incorporate it is it is it just
part of who you've been as you've grown
up
you know you know what i i i think you
know
observations are part of daily life
they're part of everything i mean people
repeat jokes that they think are funny
um people repeat mannerisms how many
people go around town imitating
christopher walken because he's just
funny he's just funny these mannerisms
are funny but
what i have a hard time with is people
that emulate actors
uh you know if some guy says what'd you
do for your character why i really
studied uh dinero
in casino and then maybe dinero was
studying
montgomery clift in this and it becomes
you know a reflection of
a faker reflecting a faker reflecting a
faker and it's not
you know i mean there's never a root of
a real person you know
um but of course everyday observations
are important i mean because that's what
you that's what you're bringing to the
screen
real life and you know you your
your your interpretation of a character
is a collection of ideas
beliefs thoughts secrets dreams and
those are things that you can pick up
anywhere
you are listening to film courage we are
live in studio with actor
sean patrick flannery you can find more
on sean by visiting
sean flannery.com would you say you're a
competitive person i mean this is a
competitive town it's competitive just
driving down ventura boulevard
yeah i mean i think you have to have an
unwillingness to lose to be in this town
because it is
pretty you know cutthroat but yeah i
think me being competitive is an
understatement of the year
um yeah
and probably least of which would be
acting
um yeah least of which would be acting
why so um
well because there's not one final
winner
okay um you know in in uh in any other
sporting event
there's one event that everybody's
shooting for in acting there's a
thousand
you know if you don't get this you're
going to get that or you're going to get
the other one or you're going to get
something else i mean
there's always there's always things in
this industry that you want
and like everybody says you know do you
do people ask me is ludicrous as me
saying do you still read for parts well
god you know uh robert downey jr
read for iron man you know i mean
everybody reads for parts
the difference is what level you're at
now certainly i don't read for iron man
i don't even
meet on that because i'm a smaller actor
but you get offered the things that you
don't want
generally speaking any of the jobs that
you do want
you have to beg and plead and that
includes you know reading form
auditioning screen testing uh
so uh it is very competitive but there's
a number of trophies that
you can strive for in a sporting event
there's really one you know
in a jiu jitsu tournament there's one
medal for my weight division
and one person's going to get it
absolutely
that's what we're segue into next is is
one of your passions outside of acting
is brazilian jiu-jitsu
um who introduced you to this art form
and does that help your acting in any
way
you know it's funny i i think all
competitive sports kind of parallel
acting in a way and there's something
you can draw and uh
and and relate to from any any
competitive sporting environment
especially into acting because it's a
very very competitive world you have to
have incredibly thick skin you got to be
able to laugh at yourself
you got to be self-deprecating you got
to be able to smile and go to sleep at
night
in the face of criticism and refusal and
you know it it's really a truly
remarkable industry
as far as seeing who can come out
unscathed it's really a test of
of a man to see who can go through this
type of industry
and not implode you know at the end of
the day
um jiu jitsu it was i think everybody
got turned on in 93 with hoyt's gracie
and ufc one
um it really answered the question of uh
you know every single martial art that
claimed to be street lethal and deadly
well at the end of the day there's only
one that really lived up to that and it
was brazilian jiu jitsu
and this skinny little wirely guy
completely dominated
everybody of every martial art i mean in
in in
a quick decisive concise manner it was
so
overwhelming that pretty much every
martial artist after that
trained brazilian jiu jitsu because all
these street lethal styles of uh
you know combat hapkido and uh all of
these other things that you know defense
against the handshake and weird
things like that everybody gravitated to
the one that really
actually did hold that magic you know in
the 70s with with kung fu but i thought
oh my god if you're a black belt you can
fight five guys and they can have
bazookas and you can kill it's just
nonsense you know
but the one that really did have that
magic where if somebody knows it you
don't
you're definitely going to lose 99 of
the time
it ended up being brazilian jiu jitsu
and that came out when they
pitted styles against styles and before
and before anybody started
cross-training
the one that answered that was bjj so i
think that's why
everybody ended up and that holds true
to this day that was still the premiere
without question it is if if if uh if
somebody gets in
in the cage that knows brazilian jiu
jitsu and the other person doesn't
they're going to lose having said that
there's not an mma fighter today that
doesn't know brazilian jiu jitsu
they all do every even the guy that uh
matt hughes is a wrestler i mean that
guy studied brazilian jiu jitsu for 10
years now
so uh yeah you can call him a wrestler
and say well he beat a bjj guy but
really matt's been studying
jiu jitsu for 10 years now so he's a
they're all cross-trained
uh athletes now so you really can't you
can't make that distinction anymore
because everybody
across the board it's the only one that
pretty much everybody does have a bit of
it in
in their system bjj let's go back to
acting for a second
some actors say that they love acting
because they get to be someone other
than themselves i mean
what do you love about acting um
i love the performance aspect i love
uh going to those you know emotional
places i love
faking it i i i i enjoy that the
performance aspect of it
i love committing to a world
that's not yours and when people say
they become this or they start
channeling that it's like you know at
the end of the day if your kid
called crying you'd break character
immediately so it's all
it's all complete there's no
channeling this or i was so lost in my
character i forgot
your child calls you crying you'll snap
the out of it immediately
um so it's all faking some people are
better fakers than others and some
people uh
really commit to to believing that
they're in that world but it's a level
of belief that can
easily be shattered by a loved one
calling in a time of crisis so anybody
that tells you i was channeling i was
like this is it's just
complete um so i love that
aspect of it i love
reading a script and going wow i'd love
to i'd love to
explore this guy but it's nothing more
than exploration you're not becoming
anybody you're the same guy at the end
of the day
you're going to a restaurant as sean
you're not going to the restaurant as
jeremy reed and powder i i don't you
don't need to call me by my character
name
you know that sounds you know
if if
if to deliver a performance of caliber
you have to become that person 24 7.
quite frankly you suck you suck you suck
at it
if it takes you training 24 hours a day
and being an to all of your
friends in order to win a gold medal you
suck as a human being
to me i mean you have to be able to
multitask you have to be able to enjoy
life
you have to be able to be kind to others
you have to
be responsible parent and then get a
gold medal
at something then you're like wow wow
what a great guy
but to deliver a performance if you're
an ass to everybody on set
and you stink because you don't want to
bathe because this guy
doesn't bathe in real life you know what
that's all easily replicatable to buy
makeup you know what i mean it's at the
end of the day it's a quality of life
thing
you know you got to enjoy what you're
doing and you have to make it easy and a
pleasant experience for everybody around
you
and there's there's some of those people
that like i became my character and
i it wasn't me yelling at you it was the
character it's like oh
shut up you just need to be needing the
dome you know
like saying crap like that
and what do you love about making movies
sean
uh realistically um i love everything
about it
i mean it it's it's it's a freebie uh
quite like i said in the
beginning of the program they pay you to
do something that you really do anyway
uh probably shouldn't hear that because
i want to continue to get paid
you know but uh we love honesty
you know realistically that's it you
know they pay you to do it um
the the they feed you whatever they take
care of you like you're a king you're
treated as royalty you get to dance with
exotic penguins it's it's absolutely
ludicrous
and at the end of the day you have uh a
movie that you'd probably
pay 12 bucks to see anyway but you're in
it it's a it's just a neat
it's it's it's neat on too many levels
to even start talking about you know you
you give a
you you your mom can go see you on
screen it's it's
every aspect of it is is uh it's a
blessing it's it's something that
everybody choose to do you know
and we touched on this earlier but i
wanted to go back to it for a second
how do you prepare for your roles i mean
we talked about kind of with acting
either
have it or you don't but do you involve
other people
in your preparation for roles and maybe
we should speak specifically
on how you prepared for your role in
boondock saints too
conor mcmanus uh you know you know the
the most important aspect i mean there's
always different viewpoints i mean i
mean
you anybody can look at a line and think
it should be delivered a certain way and
maybe
somebody you give it to another pair of
eyes and they're like oh you know what
he's talking about here he's talking
about this and you're like oh holy
i didn't even think about that
you're absolutely right he's talking
about that's a reference to something
that happened three pages earlier and
you may have not recognized that
so anytime that uh that i i need a
second set of eyes
i uh work with a fella named steven
anderson he's an acting coach here
in the valley uh and i gotta say this
one of the only
acting coaches that is not that weird
kind of guru
like follow me down the thespian path
lovey
i shall take you to thespian greatness
you know he's not one of those
fruit baskets you know he's a real guy
um
a second set of eyes but there's no guru
weirdness
it's just uh you know he can look at it
and say ah you know what he's talking
about there
if there's ever a problem i don't really
what the is this line about
i don't think it's funny i don't think
it's dramatic i don't think he's like ah
you know what it's about this and he can
find that little hole
and realistically sometimes he doesn't
and i do it's a second set of eyes but a
second set of eyes that i think
is is
is is is unparalleled to my eyes you
know we we think the same way so stephen
anderson if anybody out there
needs a second centimeter as far as the
acting goes or coaching he's got to
get in contact with um having said that
my research
from page one to fade out that's it
so you're not you're not using youtube
you're not on the internet
finding out little details you know you
tend to stick with the script
yeah i want to stick with the script i
mean if there's anything that i need to
know
that relates to the script i'll find out
but no i don't need to go
get a phd in uh
string theory to to play uh a
college math professor no i don't at all
no i don't you know but with an action
role you know something like the
boondock saints movies i mean are you
getting training though in terms of
handling weapons
yeah i mean stupid stupid little things
like that of course you know you want to
i mean if your character has to be
proficient in the use of a bread of nine
mil
you want to know how to unload that
thing load it uh drop a clip you want to
you want to look like it's your
500th a day shooting it so yeah there's
training as far as that goes but that's
a material part of the script
you know that's an active part something
that that people are going to recognize
the first time he did it or there
there's an economy of movement in
anything
you know and anything that's technical
there's you can tell if somebody's done
it every day
or somebody did it the first time you
take a key you you you
hand somebody a key to your car they've
never been in your car you'll see them
lean over the steering column look for
that damn hole to insert that two
millimeter key in it
you in your car you walk in you're on
the cell phone you're looking at a hot
chick across the street
talking on the cell phone about the
pizza you're not even looking boom that
two millimeter key goes in that two
millimeter hole
you can't you can't replicate that on
screen unless
it is your car little things like that
are
huge to the untrained eye you don't know
why but you
process that as being a little
inauthentic you don't know why
but that's it whenever you're watching
somebody and they get into their car
that they supposedly had for 30 years
and they lean over to look where the
keyhole is
you know you don't know why you're like
for whatever reason i don't believe it
i'm telling you why you don't believe it
because you just saw a guy look for
where keyhole is yeah and
told you he's been
putting it in a keyhole for 20 years
it's it just rings untrue
so little holes in people's story you
need to start plugging in as an actor
you need to know that if this is your
house for 30 years you're not going to
get up to pee and look for the light
switch
you're going to be wiping the sleepy at
it you're not looking for it boom you
hit that
three that a half a centimeter light
switch
every single time because you've done it
for 20 years
you know you can't you can't learn that
overnight
and what are some of the differences
from working on a television set to
working on a film set
um i mean would you prepare differently
for the role that
and is there a difference of working
with the tv director as opposed to a
film director
um well the directors aren't different
because some of them go back and forth
but when they're on a tv
set they're they're more regulated to
the parameters
for creativity are much more restricted
um and especially in filmmaking
well depending on if it's a studio film
with you know 18 cooks in the kitchen
sometime it can be
a little a little misleading you'll get
different direction from different
people but television is very strict in
its format
so the creative licenses is very it's
it's very narrow very narrow
comparatively speaking um
films and that right if it's an auteur
you know the writer director producer
is the same person you could explore all
types of different things
you know a director could suggest that
you shoot a scene completely differently
two times in a row
whereas television's never really going
to be like that um
there's certain coverage that for a tv
show they have to have um
for example on a movie a director may
say i'm covering this whole scene and
it's 90 seconds and i'm gonna do it in a
wide shot
it may floor somebody from you know csi
miami they're like no
you know we need 18 close-ups we need
inserts of inserts
and then when we get that insert we need
to insert that you know so
it's just a completely different
technically you know um and you but you
know that going in
you know the pace is something
completely different with tv
but the level of efficiency is much
higher on tv
you know because you know in a film a
lot of times the crew hasn't worked
together before
if you go on a show and i just did a
criminal minds
they're in their fifth year these guys
are it's like an ant hill
you know somebody reaches out to hand
somebody something that guy's not even
looking but he received he grabs it out
of their hand what even looking it's
just like
man these guys are operating at a level
of efficiency unheard of in the film
world
you know whereas in the film world it'll
take a little longer
um but they can explore a lot of
different avenues it's taken what
was it 10 years to make the sequel to
boondock saints
how hard was that on you i mean would
you have loved to do
i've done this film years before was the
right timing
um you know i i we didn't make it for uh
legal reasons we had to clear up some
legal issues so by the time you know
there was certainly an availability to
make it a long time ago but uh we had to
clear up some legal issues to
be able to make the film legally um so
now is when it happened
um yeah it wouldn't have been the same
script
uh um chronologically i think this works
out
it's ten years later there's a lot of
questions uh
that were that came out of the first
movie that are answered in this one
um i wouldn't change it you know
realistically i mean there's always
times where you know joe's like i think
we're gonna get to make it this year
i'd have been happy to have made it then
you know but for whatever reason it
didn't work out
and now all of the elements came
together i think uh
you know the fan base is hungry for uh
part two
um i think everybody was ready i think
uh
you know i'm not i'm not angry about any
of it i'm happy that we came together
right now
to the right timing yeah yeah you were
listening to film kurt
we are live in studio with actor sean
patrick flannery
we are talking about his upcoming film
the boondock saints 2 all saints day
what was it like working with troy duffy
the director troy duffy
it was killer uh it was it was uh the
same as the first time
uh you know i i imagine you guys are
getting to that uh overnight the
documentary
no we that literally that's the only
question we had but you know we'll let
you kind of take it from
yeah you know i mean everybody asked me
this question because uh you know the
the documentary
made him out to be some sort of weird
tyrant which is uh
it's uh he's not i mean he's a great cat
uh i'd work with him on a fruit loops
commercial he knows that he knew it
after the first one
um there's a reason that everybody came
back to do the second one including
people that
you know didn't have a real vested
interest in it you know like like the
the the stunt people the wardrobe people
all those people that if he was a tyrant
they'd be like this for game of
soldiers and i'll
do something else you know it's not just
the people on screen it's the people
behind the screen
everybody came back to do part two
having said that
uh it's easy to be labeled a tyrant
because i mean there's two different
types of directors they're the dress
rooms that
the directors that gather everybody
around they're like listen everyone
where we're coming from emotionally at
standpoint just
we're going to come from that place and
so that emits
you know this is like troy's
the guy that's like this
killed your dad you get in there and you
search it out
you know and he's that guy you know and
it can come across as a little bit harsh
you know if you get that on video you're
like whoa whoa look at how this guy
directs you know
yeah but he's he's a regular dude man i
mean i got a barbecues at his house it's
it was killer you know i i liked what he
did with the first film
obviously that's why i'm here i'm i'm a
fan of it
and i do i do an episode of cheers with
him you know
you know he is portrayed horribly and
overnight and you know and that's why i
want i want
someone that has the that's on the
inside to set the record straight you
know
you know i mean you know he's a straight
shooting cat a lot like myself yeah you
know uh
i'm the first person to say if you're
not pulling your weight
let's let's change something immediately
i just i don't respect people that do it
otherwise you know they're like well
let's you know for the
for there's something called the greater
good and choice you know subscribes to
that theory as well for the greater good
if this needs to be changed needs to be
changed
you know we have 30 days to shoot this
film you know we need to we need to
change something we need to change it
uh so um you know i i'm right in line
with that
you know i mean what are some of the
common mistakes you see
directors making with actors i mean
what do they need to be aware of when
working with actors well
i mean this is the only industry where
you can get
to the top tier with zero experience
so that's a wide question that uh
requires you know a couple hours of
radio time but
uh you know you have somebody that wrote
a script the script may be amazing
and suddenly they get an opportunity to
direct uh maybe they don't even know
screen direction
now this is this is one-on-one type of
stuff you don't know screen direction
you don't know how to
make it look like somebody's talking to
somebody across the table and then you
cut back and they're looking the other
direct
something as basic and fundamental as
that this person is helming
a movie and they don't even know that uh
so a lot so sometimes you'll have
something like that sometimes somebody
doesn't have
uh somebody creatively can put pen to
paper and tell a story but they have no
communicative skills whatsoever
they have no idea how to convey what
they really want to somebody else
you know so you have those problems as
well as having said that you have a guy
like troy
that's the first thing that he's ever
directed but or
quentin tarantino troy and quentin
tarantino like they love movies and they
know it so well
their first time on set you're like
this is the first time you've done this
wow you know you this this is like your
15th movie
it would appear to be you know whereas
other directors you know
there's no there's no college to go to
you know and people will put you helming
a major feature film for reasons other
than directorial talent
which is the only industry i know it to
be like that you know nobody's gonna go
do heart surgery because you know you
drew a nice heart
open me up you know slice the aorta
nobody will do that you know very true
you know and you could even say with you
know with some actors they just have a
certain look and they're thrusted into
certain roles and they don't have the
acting job yeah and
i've seen films like that you're like
man this kid is great looking man
if there was one homosexual molecule in
my being
i would blow that cat but then the guy
can't string a line again you know what
i mean you're like
i can list some actresses too they're
runway models but oh god just shut up
you know
keep the beat closed you know and what
are you looking for in your acting
career right now are you satisfied
yeah you know i mean i've i've i haven't
had the to work in 20 years
you know i haven't had to get a real job
what i consider work is something that
you wouldn't do unless somebody paid you
to do that's work
you know by definition i haven't had to
work in 20 years
um i've retained anonymity i've i've
been given the ability to pursue other
uh
passions like you know martial arts jiu
jitsu stuff like that so
i mean i i wouldn't change it for the
world you know um
i seem to have come through the industry
relatively unscathed i mean i
i don't i don't go to therapy uh i don't
you know i'm not
a scientologist i'm not i don't have any
uh
uh fruitcake uh you know uh twizzlers
in my basket uh i i i seem to i seem to
be
you know a regular guy after all of this
so uh
you know i'm happy i'm i'm excited to
have been employed in this business for
this long
uh you know certainly there's films that
i pray to god no one will ever see
you know and then films that nobody sees
that you're like man why didn't anybody
see this it was really good you know
i have that career i think everybody
does you know i i i'm content
if someone's going to succeed in this
business what do they need to be aware
of
good and bad uh
i think if somebody's going to succeed
first and foremost they have to properly
assess whether or not they have the
talent to succeed
um same thing you go into a grocery
store if you're gonna buy a hundred
dollars of groceries you gotta make sure
you got 100
bill that's just the bottom line um if
they're gonna succeed in this they have
to know that they're gonna be rejected a
thousand times
it's just like music you can take your
favorite song in the globe somebody's
going to say it sucks ass through a
silly straw
that's just the way it is you know it's
it's it's all subjective
there's no objectivity in this industry
at all so you have to know
that if you write hey jude
and you're paul mccartney you can show
that to somebody and in theory
somebody's gonna go ah
my god this shit's never gonna get get
produced as a record
uh one of my favorite books a
confederacy of dunces written by john
kennedy tool
tried to get that published years and
years and years and everybody laughed
and said it was a pile of garbage
an absolute pile of garbage one of my
favorite books um
he committed suicide his mother finally
got it published
on the best seller list for i don't know
how many years it's widely regarded as
one of the
the best literary works uh ever and and
that just
that's a story that keeps me going and
should keep everybody going
just because some executive that's never
done anything in this industry
never produced never written never
directed never done anything
tells you your project doesn't warrant
merit
if you believe it does then continue
because
the viewpoints in this industry are as
wide as the alphabet they truly are
you have people that green light things
that you see it you're like who
the gave five million dollars to
that guy to make a movie
and somebody did somebody read that pile
of bile and said oh yeah man
yeah people are gonna line up to see
this
truly and you're it's mind-boggling and
then you see something you realize whoa
that took ten years to make i can't even
believe it that's a piece of art
you know so don't get discouraged by
that because nine times out of ten the
people that are making decisions
they have less talent than you that's
great
sean it's been it's been wonderful
having you in here in studio with us
this has been a lot of fun it's gone by
really fast
we're at a point we want to make sure
people are aware of when they can see
boondock saints too
uh okay so check it out guys uh boondock
saints to all saints day comes out
valent uh valentine's well i'm on crack
tonight um
actually i am on correct tonight because
it's not tonight's today it's 10 a.m on
a sunday
um it comes out halloween night uh the
premiere is going to be the 28th at the
arclight right here in hollywood which
i'm super excited about because uh
that's the
theater that me and my girlfriend we'll
only go to movies there because it's the
theater where you can book your own
seats
so you can like lock down pole position
and get there two two minutes before
screen time and your seats still ready
and rock and waiting for it so it's
literally the best theater in l.a the
arc lights right on
sunset boulevard by the cenoramadome and
premiere's going to be there the 28th
which is wednesday it opens uh
in limited theaters in select cities on
halloween and then a couple weeks after
that it uh expands a little bit bigger
and
a little bit bigger you know depending
on if people like it you know the same
way it's a normal platform release so if
people dig the movie
then it'll go wider uh and continue to
do such until uh hopefully everybody
gets a chance to see it but uh
i'm super excited about the film i think
if you like the first one
the second one's gonna give you a boner
huge it's just it's
people gonna love this and the the
equivalent if you're a woman i apologize
sounded chauvinistic
that's a nice visual there we want to
thank you so much for being here with us
today
again for more on sean please check out
sean flannery and that's flannery with
1n.com and you can also check out his
imdb page david and i thank you for your
continued support with our show
we appreciate your emails and tweets
please join us again
next sunday on la talk radio's film
courage
you